Achtung!
Mmmmmmm xD
Geht das?
Ja.
Heute,
habe ich mal wieder das Problem,
ich habe mein iPhone
zum Laden an den Rechner gesteckt
und mein Mikrofon stellt sich auf Null.
Ich kenne den Zusammenhang nicht.
Vielleicht kennt ihr mal das Problem.
Wenn ich mein iPhone
an den Rechner gesteckt habe
und mein Mikrofon stellt sich auf Null.
Ich kenne den Zusammenhang nicht.
Vielleicht kennt ihr mal das Problem.
Wenn ich mein iPhone
an den Rechner gesteckt habe
und mein Mikrofon stellt sich auf Null.
Ich kenne den Zusammenhang nicht.
Vielleicht kennt ihr mal das Problem.
Wenn ich mein iPhone
an den Rechner gesteckt habe
und mein Mikrofon stellt sich auf Null.
Das Problem ist apple.
Android Tablet auch passiert.
Das liegt nicht an Apple, Apple stellt da bestimmt nichts um an der Lautstärke von
meinem Windows.
Wie soll es das machen?
Das ist eher Windows, was der Meinung ist, es muss Geräte wechseln und bekommt es nicht
hin oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung, ja so Dinger, die verstehe ich nicht, die leuchten mir nicht ein, die Lautstärke
habe ich nicht richtig eingestellt.
Yep, yep, alles richtig, so, easy killer, 21 Wunder, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
So, wisst ihr was wir heute machen?
VR Rates, richtig, wir machen nichts, wir machen nichts, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
ich finde Streamen mittlerweile so entspannend ist das falsche Wort, entspannend ist es nicht
wirklich, was ist das richtige Wort dafür?
Also entspannend trifft es nicht, nee, nee, routiniert auch nicht, dann wäre es ja langweilig,
chillig, erregend, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, Windows 12 Lite ausprobieren, was zum Teufel
ist Windows 12 Lite, der Rübel 17 Monat, Dankeschön für den Massive, ups, Hyper-Sub, endlich
ein Stream, der mich folgen kann, ja wie gesagt passiert heute nichts, cutebuntu, nee, das
mache ich nicht als Stream vm, ich finde es angenehm zu streamen, ich habe jetzt gedacht,
ok, ich bin heute ein bisschen kaputt, morgen übrigens Corona Leute, morgen ist soweit,
morgen um 11 oder um 10, muss ich mir mal überlegen, wann ich einen Termin habe, morgen
ist soweit, 5G Empfang wird ausgebaut, ja morgen kriege ich Corona, was heißt wieder
mehr, wir haben doch noch nie wirklich so viel Netzwerkzeug gemacht, also MikroTik WLAN einrichten
können wir machen, da muss ich aber vorher selbst mal gucken, weil das ist ein bisschen
kompliziert, welcher Chip, der da von Bill Gates, gibt es da mehrere mittlerweile, ich
dachte Bill Gates ist der einzige, gibt es da mehr, habe ich irgendwas verpasst, Elon
hat auch einen, sind das die gleichen, bei denen letztens der Tesla abgefackelt ist,
habt ihr das gelesen, letztens ist irgendein neuer Tesla abgefackelt, irgendwie ein paar
Tage nachdem er ausgeliefert wurde und der Fahrer konnte nicht raus, weil die Elektronik
kaputt gegangen ist und die Tür nicht aufging und er musste dann quasi die Tür halb zerstören,
bis er rausgekommen ist, also er ist rausgekommen, Tribool und Dankeschön, 19 Monate, Hyper
Subscription, ja das war doch, das war letztens hier, Tesla abgebrannt, ne ne ne, erst letztens
hier, irgendein neues Tesla Modell, ja Elektroautos löschen ist eh problematisch wegen der Batterie
ne, oder wegen dem Akku besser gesagt, konnte man doch jetzt auch schon, tja, übrigens
ich hab mir überlegt, ich könnte ein Video aufnehmen, du hast den Johnson & Johnson,
da ist auch Bill Gates drin, das sagen die dir plus nicht, es ist überall Bill Gates
drin, ich mein irgendwie müssen sie es ja hinkommen, die bauen jetzt überall 3G Masten
ab und 5G ist noch nicht überall da und es gibt ja dann ne ziemliche Lücke, wenn 3G
wegkommt, das ist eigentlich nur logisch, das ist Rebranded, das ist ein China Nachbau,
China Nachbau von Bill Gates, China Chinesen Nachbau von Bill Gates Chip, ne noch schlimmer,
da ist ne, ist ne Xbox drauf, genau Bill Gates Chip auf Wish bestellt, kommt bald Amazon
Basic Impfstoff, Leute macht euch da mal nicht drüber lustig, mich würde es nicht wundern,
also ohne Scheiß, es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es bald Amazon Basic Corona Zeug gebe,
und was machen Obamas Exenmenschen Bodyguards, was ist das Thema today, tja, guck in den
Titel, dann weißt du es, null, Amazon, Leute, habe ich gelesen, Amazon hat ihre, wo habe
ich denn das, Wohleham oder so, irgendwo habe ich das, Amazon Lumberyard heißt der Crapja,
Amazon hat ihre Engine open sourced, das witzige daran ist nur, ja, das Ding wollte vorher
schon keiner verwenden, das ist komplett useless, das will keiner und selbst Amazon selbst
hat keinen Bock die zu verwenden, richtig Chebated, den Crap will keiner, im Prinzip
ist es ja immer noch, guck mal hier, im Prinzip ist es ja glaube ich nur weiterentwickelt
The Cry Engine, stimmt, Jeff hat keinen Bock mehr, Vinny, vier Monate, danke für den
Bock, tja, ich weiß es ist schon ein paar Tage her, aber diese Casaya, oder wie spricht
man die aus, Casaya, Casaya, Geschichte habt ihr ja alle mitbekommen, oder, mit diesem
Softwareverteilungstool, also es gibt einen Anbieter, guck mal hier, wie schreibt man
die Casaya, spricht man die so, ja, genau, also die hier, so, ich versuche das mal für
alle die es nicht mitbekommen haben kurz zusammenzufassen, diese Firma bietet eine unter anderem
Windows Client Management Software an, also da kann man Windows Clients mit Software verteilen,
Updates verteilen, Config verteilen, Einstellungen und Updates und Dinger, so, sowas hat ja durchaus
seine Daseinsberechtigung, da kann man ja erstmal prinzipiell nichts dagegen sagen, so prinzipiell,
so, jetzt kommt es, das ist SSService, das läuft in der Cloud, das heißt du hast erstmal
tausende Windows Clients die sich in irgendeine Cloud connecten müssen für Updates, zumindest
die hatten jetzt ein Problem und zwar, findige Hackermans, da gab es einen Artikel bei, glaub
ich, ich zeige euch das mal, Casaya, wie schreibt man den Crap, Casaya, Casaya gibt es doch
auch on Brem, ja, aber, so wie ich das verstanden habe, kommen die Agent Updates wohl immer
noch aus der Cloud, deswegen sind die auch betroffen, die Agent Updates kommen wohl teilweise
oder vielleicht kann man das umstellen und das ist Default und das haben viele nicht
umgestellt, die Agent Updates kommen immer noch aus der Cloud, ja genau, ja, ja, richtig,
ja, also zumindest, zumindest lief das folgendermaßen ab, xhackeryx und supersebi, danke schön
für die Subs, also ich versuche das mal kurz zu erklären, was dabei passiert ist, und
zwar, wir kommen uns mal das Bild an, das ist übrigens das, was man dann auf seinen
Rechnern gesehen hat, bäm, erstmal schön Monero und Bitcoins Payn, löse Geld, bäm,
also im Prinzip ging es da um eine ganz normale Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner-Attacke oder, oder
wie, wie sagt Semper wie immer, Schadwehr ist da auf die, auf die Rechnern gekommen,
erstmal Schadwehr, nee Schadwehr, Schadwehr, Schadwehr kommt drauf, Schadwehr, so rum,
ist besser, Schad, Schad, Schadwahr, Schadwehr, nur ganz kurz, zumindest, ähm, wo bin ich
jetzt stehen geblieben, Mist, fuck, genau, zumindest, äh, jetzt war ich wieder, alles
wie gehabt, Festplatten wurden verschlüsselt und es wurde Lösegeld verlangt, diesmal allerdings
bis zu 70 Millionen, insgesamt bis zu 70 Millionen, das ist natürlich schon mal heftig, und ich,
ich hab mich früher immer gefragt, wer bezahlt das eigentlich, aber nachdem ich mich jetzt
ein bisschen mit diesem konkreten Fall hier beschäftigt hab, muss ich sagen, ich finde
das gar nicht so abwegig, dass das jemand bezahlt, überlegt euch mal, überlegt euch
mal, ihr seid zum Beispiel ein schwedischer Supermarkt, die davon betroffen waren, stellt
euch mal vor, ihr seid ein schwedischer Supermarkt und eure Kassen gehen nicht mehr, ihr habt
jetzt die Auswahl, sagen wir mal, ne Woche zumachen, alles fixen, richtig viel Geld reinstecken,
abcrateen, sonst was, kostet euch, keine Ahnung, 50 Millionen, man darf ja nicht gucken,
nur was das, was sich das jetzt kostet, sondern auch was du an ausfällen hast, und dann überlegt
euch, wie würde ein stonks Mensch entscheiden, wenn er die Auswahl hat, 5 Millionen Lösegeld
bezahlen oder 50 Millionen ne Woche, für 50 Millionen ne Woche zumachen, also ich finde
es gar nicht so abwegig die Idee, dass man sich dafür entscheidet und sagt, die bezahlen
das Lösegeld, zumindest Übergangsweise, zumindest Übergangsweise, und dann teilen
oder was auch immer, also wie gesagt, ich hab mir da heut mal ein bisschen Gedanken
drüber, ich find's gar nicht so abwegig, so zumindest was da passiert ist, ist folgendes,
es gibt diese Software hier von Cressaya, das ist eine cloudbasierte, cloudbasierte
Infrastrukturmanagementsoftware, was die jetzt gemacht haben ist folgendes, diese Software
ist normalerweise, also wird normalerweise nicht direkt an Endkunden verkauft, oder an
die Unternehmen, die Windows Clients oder Endgeräte haben wollen, das ist meistens
mit irgendeinem Zwischenhändler, also sprich, der schwedische Supermarkt ist zu irgendeinem
lokalen Altidienstleister gegangen und hat ihm gesagt, mach mal meine Kassensysteme
und Windows Rechner, und der hat dann gesagt, okay, machen wir, und dieser Dienstleister
verwendet hat unter anderem Cressaya Unified IT Management Software dafür, das Problem
war jetzt nur, das, also muss ich alles anfangen, normalerweise ist es ja komplett rein lokal,
Windows Software Verteilung, ich beneide übrigens, muss jemand von euch Windows Software Verteilung
machen?
Ich beneide niemand, der Windows Software Verteilung machen muss, also ich meine, ich
würde wahrscheinlich lieber kündigen, anstatt Windows Software, Rolfi, ja, richtig Sättke,
das ist das beste Emote dafür, genauso, so würde ich mich da auch fühlen, wenn ich
Windows Desktop Verwaltung machen müsste, moin Patrick, was passiert hier?
Äh, nix, wir gucken uns gerade die Geschichte an mit dem schwedischen Supermarkt und Software
Verteilung, bin ich gerade drauf gekommen, es ist, im Prinzip ist es egal, es ist egal,
was da läuft, wir hatten mal früher, Leute, die schlimmste, die schlimmste Software,
die ich je gesehen habe, für Config Management ist, weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt,
kennt das hier jemand?
Ich glaube, das gibt es gar nicht mehr, oder, gibt es das noch, ah ja, das war schrecklich,
das haben wir damals, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, verwendet, das war grausam,
das war richtig grausam, so, zumindest, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, normalerweise ist dieser
ganze Shit lokal, und Corsair hat jetzt die Möglichkeit, dass du den Kram komplett als
Service verwendest bei denen, oder so ein Zwischenschritt, äh, eine lokale Installation, allerdings
trotzdem Updates über die Cloud, also im Prinzip an der Cloud kommst du nicht vorbei, Matrix
42 hatten wir auch mal, ich frage mich immer noch, wie der Name Matrix 42 zusammengekommen
ist, das müssen doch auch irgendwelche Geeks mal gewesen sein, zumindest ursprünglich,
die das gegründet haben, sonst kommt doch keiner auf Matrix 42, Alter, das ist richtig,
das ist mehr Boomer Humor, als ich Boomer Humor habe, so, also diese zwei Varianten
gibts, allerdings ist immer diese Update Cloud Komponente dabei für den Agent, so, übrigens
hier oben, wer es aus ihrer Sicht wissen will, und jetzt ist folgendes passiert, findige
Hacker-Mans haben eine Schwachstelle auf Web-Servern von Casseya gefunden, und ich zeige euch
das jetzt mal kurz aus dem heißen Artikel, hier, das musste man aufrufen, sieht mir aus,
wie eine alte ASP.NET Anwendung, und das Problem ist nur, dass, du konntest über, ich versuche
gerade, in kürze zusammenzufassen, ich weiß gar nicht, was man hier sieht, nichts spannendes,
außer das Leute aufgerufen haben, also, diese Seite konnte man von extern aufrufen bei Casseya,
und diese Seite hätte eigentlich, also man sieht, das hat irgendwas mit Datenbanken auch
zu tun, diese Seite hätte eigentlich Passwort geschützt sein sollen, oder nur mit Login,
aber das haben sie vergessen, die Seite war einfach nicht über Alternifizierung geschützt,
die war einfach so im Internet, ohne alles, ups, kann ja mal passieren, das kann ja schon
mal vorkommen, zumindest haben sie es geschafft, über diese Seite, in die Datenbank, Dinger
reinzuschreiben, was genau weiß ich nicht, aber sie haben es geschafft, dann per wahrscheinlich
SQL Injection oder sonst wie, also der Speckend muss auch noch dementsprechend schlecht programmiert
gewesen sein, über SQL Injection in die Datenbank Sachen zu schreiben, und was sie damit gemacht
haben, ist folgendes, sie haben ein Agent Update ausgeliefert, das heißt, alle Systeme,
alle Windows Clients, die irgendwie mit dieser Unified IT Management Software verwaltet werden,
haben ein Fake Agent Update gepusht bekommen, sah aus wie ein offizielles Agent Update, war
aber ein manipuliertes Agent Update, und jetzt kommt Big Brain Time, also erstmal kommt,
wir haben Leute, wir haben beides, das liegt jetzt sehr nah beieinander, wir haben richtig
Low Brain Time und danach Big Brain Time, also wir haben richtig Six Head Time und davor
haben wir aber Massive, Massive Oi Time, und zwar dieser Agent, der auf jedem Windows Rechner
drauf sein muss, was hältst du für ein Checkmk, ne das benutzen wir nicht, aber das finde
ich in Ordnung, ich mag Nagios und das ist ja ursprünglich mal Nagios gewesen, genau
und dieser Agent, der auf allen Windows Rechnern drauf ist, der hat natürlich erstmal dieses
Update gesaugt und glücklicherweise läuft dieser Kaseya Agent natürlich mit Adminrechten,
das ist klar, ne, also was sonst, läuft mit Adminrechten, allerdings ist es damit noch
nicht gelaufen, der Kaseya Agent hat nicht nur Adminrechte, sondern Firewall-Freischaltung,
also sehr weitreichende Firewall-Freischaltung und Viren-Scanner-Ausnahmen, das bedeutet,
das Ding kann im Endeffekt machen was es will, was könnte da schon schief gehen, was könnte
da schon schief gehen, ist ja nicht auszudenken, wir sind uns ja einig, da kann ja nichts passieren
normalerweise, so, das heißt, die haben jetzt ein Update ausgeliefert und die hatten jetzt
das Problem, aber übrigens, das was ich jetzt erzähle ist meine Vermutung, aber ich glaube,
das ist recht naheliegend, zumindest meine Vermutung ist folgendes, die haben jetzt ein
Update ausgeliefert und jetzt hatten sie das Problem, sie wollten ja möglichst viel verschlüsseln
bevor es die Leute merken, das heißt man muss das irgendwie versteckt machen, man kann
jetzt nicht einfach anfangen wild die komplette Festplatte zu verschlüsseln offensichtlich,
sodass es jeder direkt merkt, also was haben sie gemacht und jetzt kommt Big Brain Time
der Angreifer, sie haben nicht nur einfach den Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner, Schadware,
die haben nicht einfach nur den Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner, den Windows Client über das Ancient Update
untergeschoben, nein und jetzt passt auf, jetzt wirds Big Brain, jetzt wirds richtig
Big Brain Time, die haben ein Windows Defender Update gepusht, was allerdings ein Downgrade
war, die haben ein Windows Defender Downgrade gepusht und zwar auf eine Windows Defender
Version, die eine Sicherheitslücke hat und dann haben sie diese Windows Defenders Sicherheitslücke
ausgenutzt, dass der Windows Defender für sie die Verschlüsselung übernimmt, das heißt
ein offiziell gesigntes Microsoft Package hat die Festplatten verschlüsselt von dem
Programm und dementsprechend hat es keiner gemerkt und dann war die Kacke am dampfen
und es war alles verschlüsselt und sie haben gesagt gibt Bitcoin oder nicht, also das ist
schon wirklich Big Brain, das haben die wirklich clever gemacht und das Fatale daran ist, dass
es bisher eigentlich immer so eine gewissen Fail gebraucht hat der Anbieterlokal, dass
sowas passiert ist, also normalerweise war das so, irgendjemand musste sinnloserweise
USB-Sticks anstecken oder ungesicherte Webseiten im Internet haben oder einen offenen Fileservoter
to Main Controller im Internet haben von den Anbietern, also von irgendeinem Unternehmen,
dass die sich sowas oder der Klassiker E-Mail Anhänge öffnen von jemand der zu viel Rechte
hat, also es musste immer lokal bisher jemand verkacken, dass man sich sowas einfangen konnte
und das war jetzt komplett was anderes, die Unternehmen haben eigentlich gar nichts verkackt
in dem Sinn, ich mein klar man kann sagen ja die haben sich auf den Cloud Softwareverwaltung
verlassen, das kann man auch schon als verkackt sehen, aber die mussten nicht aktiv was dazu
beitragen in dem Sinn, das heißt es haben ganz viele Leute jetzt abbekommen die es selbst
nicht verkackt haben, das ist abweichend von dem was sonst so ist, wie hat man eigentlich
vor 15 Jahren Softwareverteilung gemacht, ja klar es gibt schon lange, das ist halt doof
jetzt gewesen und wisst ihr was mich daran ein bisschen stutzig gemacht hat, warum ich
dazu übrigens auch ein Video aufnimm, was mich da ein bisschen stutzig gemacht hat
ist folgendes, es gab jetzt diese Solarwines, wie spricht man das noch Solarwines, Solarwines,
dieses IP Management Gedöns was ist da letztens, da haben sie auch das Problem gehabt, dass
die manipulierte, dass die den Update Server geknackt haben, manipulierte Updates ausgeliefert
haben und hier jetzt auch, so und was ich mir da gedacht habe ist, der nächste Schritt,
wenn man mal realistisch nachdenkt, der nächste Schritt ist eigentlich ein großer App Store,
was als nächstes noch mal passieren könnte, ist eigentlich naheliegend finde ich, überlegt
euch mal, die haben zwar bei Microsoft und bei Google und Apple und sonst wie, na der
Windows Store vielleicht nicht, der Windows Store benutzt ja keiner, aber zum Beispiel
der Windows Store, sagen wir mal der Windows Store oder Windows Update oder sowas in der
Richtung, wenn die da schaffen, ein getarntes Windows Update oder ein Store Update oder
ein App Store Update oder sowas rein unterzuschieben, also was, was dann auch aussieht als wärs
von Apple, dann ist vorbei, dann haben Millionen von Geräten auf einen Schlag den Kram, Google
ist gerade dabei den Laden abzusichern, ja ich gehe davon aus, dass bei Google, Microsoft
und Apple, dass da wirklich schlaue Leute arbeiten, keine Frage, die dürften mit die
schlausten Leute, teilweise zumindest, teilweise mit die schlausten Leute auf der Welt haben,
auch wenn die da für ganz schön komische Dinge manchmal machen zwischendurch, aber
ich will nicht ausschließen, dass die auch schlaue Leute haben, aber trotzdem, man darf
nicht vergessen, dass die auch nur mit Wasser kochen alle, also die können auch mal was
vergessen, die können auch mal Scheiße bauen, die können mal nicht aufpassen oder sonst
wie und da ist auch mal ganz schnell was passiert, klar man kann beliebig viele Hürden in den
Weg legen, dass es unwahrscheinlicher wird, aber es kochen alle nur mit Wasser, deswegen
gehe ich davon aus, die Frage ist gar nicht so sehr, ob das passieren wird, mal mit einem
größeren App Store, sondern die Frage ist nur, wann das passiert und ich gehe einfach
mal von aus, das wird gar nicht mehr allzu lange dauern, ich mein, guck mal, wir hatten
jetzt, wir hatten jetzt diese Chris Sire Geschichte, wir hatten jetzt diese Soda Wines Geschichte,
wir hatten über Steam, haben letztens irgendwelche Entwickler ihre PCs nicht richtig gesichert
und die haben Updates gepusht für irgendwelche Games und man darf nicht vergessen, guckt
mal, wie viel Zeug auf so einem Rechner läuft mittlerweile, mit teilweise weitreichenden
Systemberechtigungen, ich mein, der Windows Defender, der Windows Defender hat mehr Rechte
als der Admin selbst, warum wird das in letzter Zeit immer mehr, ich glaube, weil die kriminelle
Energie höher wird, weil die Leute sehen, da steckt mehr Geld dahinter, ja Browser Extensions,
zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding, auch so ein Ding, Browser Extensions, ja genau, also die
haben einfach jetzt, es haben immer mehr Leute festgestellt, dass da viel Geld dahintersteckt,
wenn man sowas macht, naja, zumindest die haben hier übrigens ein Announcement gepostet,
wo sie jetzt Zeugs erzählen, so, aber das gucke ich mir jetzt alles an, das heißt,
ich gehe davon aus, dass das demnächst auch in irgendeinem größeren App Store passieren
wird, Virus as a Service, ja, also wir werden es auf jeden Fall miterleben, das wird nicht
mal lange dauern, steht hier noch was auf der zweiten Seite drauf, ja guck, genau, das
war ich gesagt, sie haben einen Agent Hotfix ausgeliefert, das war halt ihr getanter Verschlüsselungscode,
ja, und irgendwo steht dann auch hier die Geschichte mit Windows Defender, hier, genau,
Windows Defender haben sie drauf installiert, in einer angreifbaren Version, ja, und dann
hast du dieses Teil hier gekriegt, seh ich übrigens genau so, schreibt Heiser auch nochmal
drunter, gebe ich Ihnen vollkommen recht, ja genau, SolarWinds hatten wir auch schon,
ich gebe Ihnen vollkommen recht, überlegt euch mal, das gleiche, was ich hier auch,
vielleicht hat mich auch der Heiser Artikel auf die Idee gebracht, überlegt euch mal,
was passiert, wenn Microsoft, Apple oder Google das betrifft, und das wird passieren, wenn
wir Glück haben, dann nicht im ganz so großen Stil, sondern nur irgendwie eingeschränkt
auf ein paar spezielle Sachen, aber das wird auf jeden Fall auf uns zukommen, und das blöde
ist, das wird früher oder später jeden von uns treffen, du kannst dich da eigentlich
gar nicht dagegen wehren, was willst du machen, du kannst deine Geräte nicht mehr ohne App
Store verwenden, Android kannst du theoretisch schon ohne App Store verwenden, aber macht
kaum einer, iOS verwendet niemand ohne App Store, ja, du kannst den Internet, du kannst
die beste Firewall der Welt nehmen, ne Zange, ja, aber wer betreibt ein iOS Gerät ohne
den App Store, Microsoft macht jetzt auch immer stärkere Pushs zu ihrem Windows Store,
und im Zweifelsfall ist es eh vielleicht nicht der Microsoft Store, sondern es ist vielleicht
eure Xbox, die dann lokal im Netzwerk hängt und übernommen ist, oder es ist Steam, es
kann auch ein Steam Update sein, da helfen nur Backups, genau, das ist realistisch betrachtet,
das einzige, was du machen kannst, sind Backups, und nicht einfach jeden Tag irgendwie immer
überschreiben, sondern du musst schon mal mindestens eine Woche das vorhalten, weil
sonst verschlüsselst du nach und nach deine Backups mit, also es ist echt kritischer Hase,
gibt's den überhaupt noch? Gibt's Apo Red überhaupt noch? Keine Ahnung, ich bin in
der deutschen YouTube Szene nicht unterwegs. Gibt's den noch? Okay, zeig mal, zeig mal
her. Ah, hier, Musik, der macht Musik? Oh, das kann ich jetzt nicht abspielen, Moment
mal, der macht Musik, okay. Alter, ist das Auto-Tune-Rap? Lass mich raten, das ist so
eine Art Auto-Tune-Rap. Also, das würde mich jetzt zumindest nicht wundern, wenn's das
wäre. Irgendwie macht jeder, jeder, der nicht singen kann, Auto-Tune-Rap. Ne, ne, ich höre
nicht rein, das ist Mokathos, das kann ich nicht im Stream machen. Zwei Sekunden regeln,
ich mache hier nichts im Stream an, kannste vergessen. Mein damaliger IT-Lehrer hatte
seine Webcam am Laptop abgeklebt. Ja, das kann man auch machen. Ich hab mir übrigens
auch überlegt, ob ich mir nicht mit meinem 3D-Drucker so einen Kameradings-Aufsatz, Moment,
Moment. Was ist an Vierenschutz gefährlicher als der Microsoft-Default-Vierenschutz? Ich
finde, man braucht keinen zusätzlichen Vierenschutz, wenn man das Microsoft-Default hat. iPhone,
ich will so ein Kamera-App-Plende, Kamera-Plende zum Selbstausdrucken, die man einfach abmachen
kann. Aufkleber sind doof, Aufkleber kriegt man nicht so einfach wieder ab. Was? What
the fuck? Was ist das? Hä? Ah, ah, das ist zu anstrengend, YouTube-Videos zu gucken,
wenn man das mit den Armen festhält. Okay, das verstehe ich, ja. So ist natürlich deutlich
besser und ergonomischer, das verstehe ich. Natürlich. Klingt logisch. Klar. Laufen wir
so durch die Stadt. In Frankfurt hat dir einer in zwei Minuten das Handy geklaut. Kaumuskel
ist der stärkste Muskel. Das habe ich auch mal gelesen, aber wahrscheinlich für die,
wahrscheinlich für die Größe. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn du dir irgendwas
im Rücken oder im Oberschenkel anguckst, für die Größe ist das bestimmt stärker. Aber
für die Größe. Versuch mal eine Nuss mit dem Oberschenkel zu... Hä? Das ist doch an
sich gar kein Problem. Du musst halt gucken, wie du sie platzierst. Mach dir mal ein Nussknacker,
leg dir ein Nussknacker unter den Oberschenkel, drück nach unten. Na gut, Nussknacker ist
doof, das ist vom Hebel her anders. Aber davon abgesehen, mit dem Mund zerknacken ist sicherlich
auch nicht so angenehm. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Mit solchen anatomischen Sachen, Nackenmuskulatur
ist auch übelst stark. Ja, was was auch immer. Ich sehe anatomisch kennen sich die Leute
wieder richtig gut aus. Habt ihr mal gesehen, das gibt Leute, die können eine Flasche öffnen
mit dem Ohr. Ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden, wie das funktioniert. Ich stelle mir das schmerzhaft
vor. Ich wüsste auch gar nicht, wie das gehen soll. Aber vielleicht ist das auch fake und
die machen es in Wirklichkeit mit der Hand oder so. Mit dem Ohr, keck bei. Hier, F.
Wie weit bist du mit deinem Minprogramm? Ich hab nicht weiter gemacht. Ich meine, es funktioniert
ja. Aber es ist immer noch die alte Version, die ein bisschen laggt. Jailer, du hast echt
nichts verpasst. Ich habe mich nur gerade über diese Kaseya, wie spricht man das eigentlich
auch Kaseya ausgelassen. Hast nichts verpasst. Ich mach da morgen ein Video zu. Da sage ich
einfach genau das, was ich jetzt im Stream gesagt habe und gut ist. Ja, lass mal überlegen,
ist noch irgendwas interessantes passiert? Ach ja, diese Printer Geschichte, diese Printer
habt ihr ja wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt, was da bei uns witzig auf der Arbeit ist. Ich
weiß gar nicht, wann schließt denn das Microsoft offiziell heute? Okay. Was witzig ist, diese
Drucker Sicherheitslücke, die ist ja eigentlich nur relevant, wenn die Systeme im Internet
sind so wirklich, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, bei uns auf der
Arbeit patchen sie das jetzt auch und das haben die angekündigt. Wir haben so eine Runde,
die ist einmal die Woche, da werden Wartungsarbeiten des Tages und der Woche besprochen und da
haben die das angekündigt, als wäre das jetzt quasi heute, als wäre das jetzt quasi der
neueste heiße Scheiß, der jetzt ganz frisch ist und da habe ich dann mal nachgeguckt,
ja Moment, das gab es doch schon letzte Woche, Donnerstag. Und es spricht, wir haben, wir
brauchen eine Woche, um so einen Scheiß zu fixen. Da können wir es uns auch eigentlich
sparen, weil entweder wurde das in der Zwischenzeit schon ausgenutzt oder es interessiert keinen
mehr. Nee, Twitch Wort lade ich nicht auf YouTube hoch. Jetzt patchen, yep, patch. Moment,
ist Windows 2012, ist das ernsthaft, ist das immer noch supported? Und warum ist 1607 noch
supported? 1607, das ist fünf Jahre alt. Ach ist das LTS. Aber warum ist Windows 2012
R2 nicht mehr support? Was ist denn R2? Ach 2008. Ja gut, das kannst du machen jetzt im,
ja, ich rede jetzt, ich rede jetzt von Kisten daheim. Ich rede jetzt von Kisten daheim.
Moment, dass du das in deinem Netzwerk auf der Arbeit nicht haben willst, ist klar. Shard
Code. Tja, gut, hatten wir uns das auch angeguckt. Ich habe legit, echt keine Ahnung, ich geh
mal, ich gucke mal durch, ob es irgendwie ein paar nice questions, hast du schon mal
was zu GitHub Copilot gesagt? Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann da nicht zu viel zu sagen, ich hab
das aus, ich hab das nicht ausprobiert. Also wer es noch nicht kennt, GitHub Copilot ist
eine neue AI von Microsoft für Code Completion, also von GitHub, ist ja im Prinzip Microsoft
und du schreibst einen Kommentar, was es für dich programmieren soll und machst Autovervollstellung
und es programmiert das für dich. Ja, ich habe letztens im Stream schon was zugesagt,
ich finde den Ansatz echt interessant und ich gehe davon aus, dass, warum ist die Musik
auf einmal so laut? Und ich gehe davon aus, dass sich viel tun wird in Zukunft, gerade
im Hinblick dessen, dass zum Beispiel so Sachen wie, sagen wir, irgendwelche Bilderkennungssoftware,
die dir quasi eine Textbeschreibung liefert für ein Bild, dass die durch solche Sachen
eventuell sogar in der Lage ist, sich selbst zu optimieren. Man muss sie einfach nur viel
durchprobieren. Das wäre auf jeden Fall eine coole Idee, dann ist Terminator nicht mehr
weit, wobei sowas wahrscheinlich nicht passieren wird, das glaube ich ein bisschen zu schwarz
gemalt immer, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass auf einmal eine Bilderkennungssoftware,
die sich AI-technisch dann irgendwie verbessern kann, auf einmal der Meinung ist, sie will
jetzt die Weltherrschaft und lässt Flugzeuge abstürzen oder sowas, also das ist dann doch
im Bereich eher Science-Fiction anzusiedeln. Aber ich finde vom Ansatz her interessant,
ob sich das wirklich großartig lohnt, aktuell wage ich zu bezweifeln. Die Idee ist auf jeden
Fall nice, kein Patch für XP, was soll das überhaupt, auch kein Patch für Windows 7
oder gibt es einen Patch für Windows 7? Für Vista, wie sieht es mit Vista aus? Moment,
ich bin verwirrt, Vista war nach XP oder? Warte mal, es war XP, Vista, Windows 7, Windows
8, 8, 1 und 10, oder? Ist das richtig? Ja, ok. Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zu VR
Gaming? Das neue Half-Life ist mega poggers, aber allein, ich will mir keine 3D-Brille
kaufen, nur dafür, oder VR sagt man ja heute, 3D-Brille ist Boomer-Boomer-Language, das
sagt man ja nicht mehr. Welches Lidlungsfindest du am besten für Desktop oder Server? Jede
Influencer recycelt Streams, ja, da muss ich das ja nicht auch machen. Ich kaufe mir einfach
für 50€ im Monat so einen indischen Cutter, da mache ich einen Highlight-Channel, der
schneidet mir das dann zusammen. Wobei, wobei es gibt ja eigentlich gar keine Highlights
im Stream, was soll man da zusammenschneiden? Oder du machst einen for free, das kannst
du auch machen, da bin ich auch dabei. Ja, 700 FPS mindestens. Ne, das Simón machen
wir nicht. Mal auf Pfeifer, ja ich habe schon öfters mal ein paar Sachen bestellt auf Pfeifer.
So, gibt es irgendwelche Questions, die ich übersehen habe? Was, Augenschmerzen? Was
war? Irgendeine Seite? Ja, habe ich den Dark Mode ausgemacht? Ne, gibt nichts. Gibt nichts.
Nix im Chat, weil ich beantworten kann. Wie gesagt, ich habe wohl für den Stream echt
nichts geplant, ich habe gedacht, ich komme einfach mal an. Also, wie man vor 15 Jahren
Softwareverteilung gemacht hat, eigentlich, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, nicht viel anders
als heute. Es war vielleicht aber mit nicht ganz so viel Hype-Technologie. Heute brauchst
du ja mal mindestens 20 Sachen SS-Service und CI, CD, was hast du nicht gesehen? Pipeline.
Damals hast du ein Skript gebastelt, was einfach alles überall hin kopiert hat. Das war vielleicht
nicht so agil und cool, aber im Prinzip nicht viel Unterschied. Welches Lidungs empfiehlst
du Desktop? Manjaro. Wenn man sich ein bisschen mit Lidungs beschäftigen will oder ein bisschen
Erfahrung hat, Manjaro finde ich mit Abstand am leistesten. Wie viele Urlaubstage sind
deiner Meinung nach als fisi angemessen? So viel wie geht. Immer so viel wie geht. 30
dürfte so Standard sein. Gesetzlich ist glaube ich 26, ne, aber ich habe eigentlich selten
gesehen, dass es unter 30 ist. Bewindest du XFCE? Ne, ich verwende, ich kann ja mal meine
VM starten. Poggers VM. Was? 22? 22 ist doch gesetzlich gar nicht erlaubt, oder? Ist nicht
26 das Mindeste? 20 Tage bei einer 5? Ernsthaft? Wirklich? 20? Das ist ja nichts. Also ich
habe E3 hier als Window Manager, wie du siehst, ist meine. Ups. Hallo, was ist denn hier?
Warum ist die Historie korrupt? Jetzt nicht mehr. Gefällt mir, gefällt mir mit Abstand
am besten. Warum habe ich denn 1 und 1 hier auf? Und was ist das hier? 3 Head? Was habe
ich da auf? Ah, okay. Ach, das war das Azure Portal, ja, das können wir löschen. Wobei,
da habe ich den Account gerade einmal für. Die können entschlüsseln, diese ganzen Verschlüsselungs-
kriana-Dinger, die legen da glaube Wert darauf, dass man es entschlüsseln kann, weil sonst
spricht sich ja rum, dass man nicht entschlüsseln kann und es bezahlt sonst keiner mehr. Das
finde ich gut. Das mache ich nochmal rein. Das finde ich, das finde ich gut. Wie gesagt,
Hack-MK habe ich selbst noch nicht verwendet, aber da war mal Nagios drunter. Hacker-Angriff
auf Kreisverwaltung. Ach, ist das auch? Sind die auch von Kezia? Ist das das gleiche? Steht
nichts da, ne? Ist aber, es ist aber zeitlich schon ziemlich naheliegend, ne? Interessant.
Auf der anderen Seite muss nicht unbedingt so sein, weil man ganz im Ernst, da muss ich
wahrscheinlich, da muss ich wahrscheinlich ein Admin um 500 Endgeräte kümmern, plus
das Netzwerk, plus Storage, plus Rechenzentrum, plus Hardware. Also sie haben einen Admin,
der macht wahrscheinlich alles. Dann ist kein Wunder, dass sowas passieren kann. Du kannst
dich nicht auf alles achten. Wahrscheinlich wollen sie jetzt noch den armen Admin verklagen
am Ende. Max ist der zoomigste Boomer, den ich kenne, ja, finde ich auch. Ja, also zumindest
diese Kezia-Geschichte, sowas ähnliches könnte mit Linux natürlich auch passieren, wenn
die Package Manager Sources irgendwie unterwandern. Wahrscheinlich Windows, das kann ich mir bei
denen gut vorstellen, dass da noch Windows XP drauf war. Das kann ich mir, das ist gut
möglich. Wobei die ja auch Windows 7 teilweise noch im Einsatz haben und dafür jetzt extra
bezahlen, dass Microsoft ihn noch supportet. Ne, warte mal. Doch, ne, 7 war das, die Extended
Support gekauft haben. Borderlands 2, bestes Game. Ne, nicht bestes Game. Auf jeden Fall
ein nicees Game. Haben ja schon ein paar probiert. Die ging ja meistens nach hinten los. So eine
Mischung aus Unwollen und Unfähigkeit. Ja, die, was bei denen abgeht, verstehe ich nicht.
Kennst du Skyland? Ist mega useless. Ne, kenne ich nicht. GitHub. Yo GitHub Story in 3D.
Und ich mal ausprobieren. Ah, geht nicht. Vielleicht weil ich kein, ne. The fuck ist
das? Was sehe ich da? Ah, okay, das ist wirklich mega sinnlos. Kann ich 3D drucken? Meine GitHub
History. Top. Das ist ein gutes Emote. Das habe ich gleich schon drinne. Also wenn ihr
Refresh den Chat habt, könnt ihr das verwenden. Ich habe es gerade hinzugefügt. Beste. Der
Chandler hat immer die besten aktuellen Emote Trends am Start. Oh, das war aber großzügig.
Das ist aber großzügig. Wahrscheinlich weil ich irgendwelche Fonts nicht installiert habe.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es zu wenig ist. Dachte 26. Ja und nein. Also dazu kann ich
folgendes sagen. Ich habe da keine Angst vor, weil ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass
das passieren wird, wenn ich mir manche Security Sachen bei uns angucke. Juckt mich aber auch
nur am Rande. Mehr als sagen kann ich nichts. Ich meine wir haben Passwörter, die quasi
fast schon an 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 rankommen bei manchen Diensten. Da muss man sich nicht
wundern, wenn das in die Hose geht. Wir hatten übrigens schon mal so eine Art Verschlüsselungs-Droianer.
Ist aber zum Glück recht schnell eingedämmt worden. Das liegt daran, weil sich niemand
traut das zu enablen. Weil die da sehr fragwürdig E-Modes drauf haben. Desktop Assessor, denn
IDE Assessor gibt es schon. Da stehe ich ja auch so auf Kriegsfuß mit. Nicht als Admin,
sondern nur als User. Wir hatten das mal eine Weile, da konntest du eine Windows vor allem
über einen Browser verwenden. Über Zitricks. Und das hat gelaggt. Das war laggy as fuck.
Du hast was aufgemacht und das hat irgendwie 5 Sekunden rumgezuggelt bis du überhaupt
mal reinklicken konntest. Das war ganz ganz schlimm. Wird das Speedchamp jemals fertig?
Gute Frage. Müssen wir noch weitermachen. Mach ich. Mach ich. Was? Was ist das? Step
up your coding game. Da muss man ziemlich big brain sein, oder? Was? Was zum? What the
fuck? Ihr gebt mir eine ordentliche Programmiersprache. Da bin ich jetzt zu low brain für solche
Sachen. Da bin ich, habe ich keinerlei Gehirnkapazitäten mehr frei. Wie gesagt, Desktop mag ich am
liebsten man Jaro i3 WM. Das schöne an i3 ist, dass es einfach auch gut in der VM läuft,
wie du hier siehst. Es läuft top. Wunderbar in der VM. Mal davon abgesehen, dass man Fenster
resizing nicht braucht, aber ich jetzt trotzdem mal mache. KDE mag ich nicht. Naja, mach
ich ja meistens. What the fuck? Horgazmusik. Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das? Was
ist das? Paper please hier. Wie hast du die i3 status bar so verändert? Das ist i3 status
rust nennt sich das. I3 status rs. Kannst du dir installieren. Und dann hast du so eine
coole status bar, die noch mehr kann. Sehr gut. Hast du dir schon die Themes in Winners
Termin angeguckt? Nope. Wie heißt deine Playlist? Die Playlist ist gerade hier auf YouTube. Beachside
Nintendo Summer Music Mix. Jawoll. Wäre es nicht sinnvoll, ein Programm zu entwickeln,
was unabhängig immer nach Installationen oder Updates testet, ob alle möglichen Dateien
aufrufbar sind und bei einer Verschlüsselung... Ja, sowas gibt es schon. Es gibt schon Software,
die quasi darauf spezialisiert ist, quasi Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner zu erkennen, die
anfangen zu verschlüsseln. Gibt es schon. Auf die Idee sind Security Leute schon gekommen.
Schon gelesen RPM Schlüsselprobleme. Nee, nicht gelesen, aber es ist klar, dass Linux
da prinzipiell die gleichen Probleme hat. Also wie gesagt, das gibt es schon. Und KDE
mache ich echt nicht so. Leute, ich penne gleich ein. Ich hätte nicht online kommen
sollen, wenn ich eh schon müde bin. Zumal ich habe null vorbereitet für den Stream. Ich
verstehe auch nicht, wie Leute so was 5-6 Stunden am Tag durchziehen können. Es gibt
so viele Streams, gerade wenn du in Just Chatting guckst, die haben einfach nur den Chat auf
und lassen den ganzen Tag den Chat laufen und pennen da quasi halb dabei. Was ist das
hier? Is your memory leaking? Die Antwort ist wahrscheinlich einfach Yes. Monka Toss. Der
Fehler ist ja schon Javascript. Bestimmt. Ja. Das ist das, was ich auch schon öfters
im Stream gesagt habe und manche Leute sagen, das stimmt nicht. Ich habe gesagt, dass man
ohne Probleme auch in Managed Sprachen, sei es C Sharp, Pi's und Java Memory Leaks produzieren
kann. Warum sollte das nicht gehen? Und dann sagt der Chat immer, nein Max, das geht nicht,
wir haben einen Garbage Collector, da kann man keine Memory Leaks produzieren. Ich habe
es irgendwann aufgegeben. Aber wisst ihr, der Chat hat aus Prinzip immer recht. Der
hat noch nie was falsches gesagt. Ahja, exellent, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Website namens FPS, na klar. DNS Explained, nee, please, please, das halte ich heute Abend
nicht mehr aus. DNS ist auch so ausgeburt der Hölle. Aber wenigstens funktioniert es
im Vergleich zu anderen solcher Dinger. Warum Windows 95 ein Big Deal war?
Na ja, vergleicht es mal mit Windows 3.1, da ist es wahrscheinlich relativ oft sichtlich.
Ich glaube, es war das erste richtig 32-bit Windows und es war im Prinzip ist Windows
95 das Windows, was Windows von der Optik zu dem gemacht hat, kann man jetzt gut oder
schlecht sehen, zu dem gemacht hat, was es heute ist. Guckt euch Windows 95 an, von den
Grundzügen ist es heute immer noch so. Übersicht bedingte Wahrscheinlichkeit, ah jetzt, das
brauche ich heute Abend unbedingt noch. Weiß jemand, wieso meine Maus in Mancharo XFCD
irgendwie 60 Hertz aussieht bei Bewegung? Keine Ahnung. Mini, oh was ist denn das? Ok,
es ist nicht do-it-yourself-perk-channel, dann kann man sich das schon mal angucken.
Ok, Moment, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, das sieht tatsächlich ganz spannend aus.
Warte mal her. Ah, das gute, das gute OLED, nee nicht OLED, das gute SSD 1306, ist das
glaube ich Display, oder? Oder Display? Ja. Was hast du gegen DIY-Perks, die zwei Videos,
die ich von ihm gesehen habe, waren alle jetzt, haben mich vom Produkt her nicht so überzeugt.
Nein, nein, Raspberry Pi sackt als Nass. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum alle immer ankommen
und aus dem armen Raspberry Pi einen Nass bauen wollen. Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Ich meine, man kann das machen, aber die beste Wahl ist es auf gar keinen Fall. Hast du schon
eine Cloud-Idee probiert? Ja, ich habe mal früher eine Weile Cloud 9 verwendet, so Just
for Fun, immer mal wieder, aber das gibt es glaube ich mittlerweile nicht mehr oder wurde
von Amazon gekauft oder sowas. Ich habe letztens Code Anywhere oder so probiert, nee wie hieß
das? Code Anywhere, ist das so? Das habe ich letztens ausprobiert, das machte mir einen
ganz guten Eindruck und ich habe zwei Stück letztens ausprobiert. Cloud-Idee, was habe
ich letztens ausprobiert? Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das, das, das oder? Ich habe irgendwas
anderes ausprobiert. Keine Ahnung. Was das Beste ist für einen Nass, ich bin am
Meinen, irgendeine Low-Power-Intel-Plattform ist preisleistungsmäßig das Beste. Da kriegst
du Boards für 70 Euro inklusive CPU, also das ist ein komplettes Board mit aufgelöteter
CPU und Passivkühler und du hast, je nach dem, je nach Auswahl, hast du genug Steckplätze,
SATA oder sogar einen ordentlichen PCI Express oder vielleicht sogar mehrere PCI-Expresse,
Anschlüsse, teilweise sogar mehrere Netzwerktings, also da musst du gucken, da gibt es ein paar
gute Boards und wenn du das dann auch in Gehäuse steckst mit irgendeinem Wechselrahmen drinne,
dann ist das ganz ok als Nass, aber das kannst du doch knicken. So, weiter. Ok, was macht
der? Ein Raspberry Pi Server Bild in UPS. Ok, das finde ich interessant. Ich habe unten
im Keller den Raspberry Pi Zero, da habe ich auch eine USB dran, also auch sowas in der
Richtung. Ich habe mir mal bei den chinesischen, China-Chinesen so einen Adapter gekauft, da
machst du ja auch diese 18, wie heißen diese Batterien? 1856 oder so? Die E-Zigaretten-Batterien-Akkus
sind das. 18650, genau. Genau, die meine ich. Machste rein und dann erkennt das, wenn du
es rausstöpselst und mach das unterbrechungsfrei über die Batterie. Sowas habe ich auch am
Raspberry Pi Zero unten im Keller dran. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange es hält. Hast du das
mit Zoll aus China schon mitbekommen? Ja, aber ich glaube immer noch, dass das nicht
viel ändern wird. Weißt du, warum ein DHT22 10 Grad zu viel anzeigt? Weil die DHT22 nicht
sonderlich geil sind. Du kannst die Dinger aber auch irgendwie kalibrieren. Frag mich
aber nicht mehr, wie das geht. Es gibt irgendwie die Möglichkeit, die zu resetten oder so.
Musst du mal gucken, dann pendeln die sich ein bisschen besser ein. So, gucken wir mal.
China. Im China. Wobei für China sieht das fast schon ein bisschen ordentlich beschriftet
aus. Ist das China? Ich muss gucken, ob das China ist. Ist das China? Ah, China. AliExpress.
Die Commodits sind am Start, jawoll. Ok, chinesische China, Chinesen. Aber das ist
wenigstens ordentlich beschriftet. Oh, der hört sich ja super gehypt an in dem Video.
Ich habe bei diesen Akku einschümmen immer das Problem, die sind nicht verpolungssicher.
Sowohl vom Einlegen her, als auch von der Elektronik. Ist wenn du es falsch rum einlegst,
macht es dann bonker Smoke. Ich wollte da 20W rauskriegen. Ja gut, ich glaube 4A ist
das Maximum, was so ein Akku liefern kann, oder? Mehr wird wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
Aber 20W aus denen stelle ich mir jetzt sportlich vor. Mark NCS, dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Oh, Knopf. Allerwichtigste, dass da unten ein orangener Knopf ist.
Du hast für massiven IQ Increase gesorgt im Chat, weil wie ihr wisst, kann man nicht
oft genug betonen, jeder Sub IQ++ für den Chat. Ich wollte gerade sagen Tier 2 ist IQ+++,
aber Tier 2 macht keiner, was ich auch verstehen kann, weil ich keine Tier 2 und Tier 3 Abos
habe. Äh, nee, nicht Abos. Siehste mal Leute, Boomer hier in Time. Ich meine Emotes. Medminister,
siehste? Hat schon funktioniert, ich glaube es fühlen sich alle instant intelligenter.
Das passt aber nice da drauf, muss ich sagen. Ich habe immer bei den Leuten eine ernst gemeinte
Frage, warum überhaupt ein Case, also je nachdem wo du es hinstellen willst, ist so
ein, rein Optik vollkommen klar, versteh ich ja, aber je nachdem wo du es hin machen willst,
du musst es ja nicht offen hinlegen. Kannst du ein Case einfach sparen? Wegen der Freundin,
und dann versteckt das Teil hinterm Schrank oder so. Ahja, aber ok, ich lasse mich gefallen.
Außerdem sind wir noch mal realistisch. Die Kombination aus Freundin haben und Raspberry
Pi rumbasteln, kommt doch eh selten vor. Ich weiß, ich weiß, die Wahrheit Schmerz Chat.
Das hat er schick gemacht. Das hat er schick gemacht. Chat, nicht traurig sein, ihr wisst
doch, dass ich die Sachen alle, dass ich so ziemlich alles, was ich sage, immer nur zur
Hälfte ernst mein. Also das Gehäuse muss echt, was denn das? Was ist das für, ach
das ist Inkscape. Ok, das sieht immer noch so hässlich aus wie vor 10 Jahren.
Oh guck mal, der hat einen Laser Cutter. Ich hab mir ja schon kurz, Leute ich kaufs mir
nicht, aber ich fand das Gerät schon echt nice. Ich hab letztens ein Video gesehen,
das war ein 3D Printer, Laser Cutter, CNC all in one, genau. Der da ist das, genau,
Snapmaker. Snapmaker 2.0. Der ist ich letztens ein Video von gesehen, hier von ihm, von
ihm. Und ich muss sagen, ich fand das Gerät schon massiv geil, aber ich brauchs nicht,
ich brauch es nicht. Ich muss mir aufhören teilweise so Dinger zu kaufen, nur weil ich
geil finde. Ich mein, es ist schon cool, oder? Es ist schon cool. 3D Drucker, Laser und CNC
in einem Gerät. Dankeschön, Stripes, für den Resub. Ich hab's gar nicht gesehen. Was
waren das? War das das, wo ich grad am labern war vorhin? Dankeschön für den Sub. Auf
jeden Fall Hypersubscription hier von der Dauer her schon. Es ist schon cool, es ist
schon nice. Gut, 3D Druck juckt uns nicht. Ihr Laser mit Kamera. Du kannst Sachen ausschneiden,
du kannst Sachen gravieren. So eine MP-CNC, was ist denn MP? Multi-Purpose-CNC, kann das
sein? Gibt es keinen Makerspace, doch bestimmt, aber da müsste man sich ja im Real Life mit
Leuten treffen. Ich glaub, es geht los. Was hältst du eigentlich von fertigen, nass,
wie Cyanology? Kann man sich kaufen? Sind gar nicht so schlecht. Das ist schon, das ist
schon cool. Vor allem, dass da auch noch eine CNC dabei ist, ist schon echt nice. Ist halt
teuer, ne? Ist halt teuer. Wir haben glaub ich letztens mal, jetzt günstig kaufen, ok
gucken wir mal, was günstig, was günstig, günstig, günstig ist. Wir haben aber glaub
ich schon mal geguckt. Ich glaub, bis zu 2000 Euro oder so los. Äh. Hallo? Ah. Ein Schnapper,
2300 Euro. Ich glaub, es liegt aber auch an der Größe, gibt's auch noch kleiner. Also
das kleinste 1500. Das kleinste kostet nicht 1500 Euro. Das ist halt schon ordentlich,
ne? Und natürlich ist es schon ein geiles Gerät, muss man sagen, aber ich sollte mir
auch für sinnlose Dinger zu kaufen. Aus dem Weg geringverdiener. Wobei es halt, es ist
nice, wenn du sowas hier cutten kannst. Sag doch mal, das ist doch echt. Oh guck mal,
da unten ist es angebrannt. Es ist aber trotzdem, es ist nice. Kannst nix sagen. Und das Gehäuse,
das Gehäuse ist auch echt, naja ok, ich wollt grad sagen, jetzt echt sauber gedruckt zum
größten Teil. Doch das ist sinnlos. Also sinnvoll wäre es, wenn ich das Gerät öfters für
was brauchen würde oder öfters wenigstens nicht brauchen mag ich sagen, wenn ich wenigstens
öfters für was benutzen würde. Zweimal im Jahr, wenn's hoch kommt, wenn's hoch kommt,
wenn's hoch kommt. Mein 3D Drucker benutze ich mittlerweile hin und wieder, aber das andere
Zeug, zumal ich kann's auch gar nicht in meinen Serverraum stellen, das müsste ich
irgendwo anders hinstellen, weil da ist kein Platz. Du musst ja so eine Sicherheitsabdeckung
machen, dass du den Laser verwenden kannst. Ja gut, dass das nicht so gut ist wie einzelne
Geräte ist klar. Dafür brauchste auch weniger Platz. Also ich hab das, das hab ich schon
geschafft. Das erste Mal, als ich in das, was ich ja von AliExpress gekauft hab, das,
was ich bei AliExpress gekauft hab, ist im Prinzip das hier nur mit einem Einschub,
nicht mit zwei. Das erste, was ich gemacht hab, ist Batterie eingelegt, aus Versehen
falsch rum und es hat angefangen zu schmoren. Natürlich, Profi-CNC ist das, die 500k kosten
bezweifle ich nicht, aber trotzdem muss ich schon zugeben, also für ein Gerät, was man
vielleicht alle zwei Jahre einmal verwendet, ist es trotzdem nicht sonderlich gut investiert,
das Geld. Ja, deswegen sollte man auch Sachen nicht kurz schließen.
Wackelt das nicht? Ah gut, jetzt hat er es so festgeschraubt, da wackelt nichts mehr.
Guck hier, sag doch, das gute SSD 1306 OLED Display. Davon hab ich bestimmt auch noch
ein 30er Pack oder so im Schrank. Muss jetzt nicht übertrieben, ihr wisst ja, ich kaufe
nie einzelne Stücke.
Was bedeutet GPIO? Ja, KitKarty hat schon geschrieben. General Purpose Input Output.
Wie soll man das erklären? Das sind Pins, die kannst du per Software ein- und ausschalten.
Oder eben manche haben noch die Möglichkeit, dass du, also beim ESP32 haben viele Pins
dann noch einen Analog-Digital-Converter dahinter. Aber ansonsten, in der Regel kannst du die
Pins ein- und ausschalten oder erkennen, ob was ein- und ausgeschaltet ist. Also mit
1 ausgeschaltet ist, über 2,5V ist eingeschaltet und unter 2,5V ist ausgeschaltet. Also offiziell
sind es natürlich 3,3, aber meistens tut es mit 2,5 schon.
Ein RGB-Lüfter natürlich, was sonst? Siehste, der ist einfach nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand.
RGB-Lüfter sind aus, BGR-Lüfter sind in. Das wissen die Noobs aber nicht. Es sieht
doch ganz hübsch aus, was er da gebaut hat. Hat er das gekuttet mit seinem Laser? Wow,
das ist cool. Also so dieses Acrylic- oder wie heißt das? Glass-Zeug-Cut. Also dafür
stelle ich mir so einen Laser-Cutter schon echt extrem nice vor. Ich würde wahrscheinlich
ne Woche nur irgendwelche Glass-Dinger cutten, weil ich es kann und danach nie wieder verwenden.
F. Wisst ihr was ich gemacht hätte? Ich bin faul was sowas angeht. Ich hätte Heißkleber
genommen und hätte das zugepappt. Oder aber, ich hätte die Schrauben so fest angezogen,
dass es oben und unten festen sitzt und hier in der Mitte Luft hat. Wahrscheinlich hätte
ich Heißkleber genommen. Wobei das natürlich kontraproduktiv ist, wenn du es wieder aufkriegen
willst. Oh der ist so motiviert in dem Video. Das ist cool. Ne ich kauf mir sowas nicht.
Das Coole bei so einem Cutter ist, dass geht halt viel viel schneller als 3D-Drucken. So
so ein Glass-Ding ausgeschnitten hast du wahrscheinlich in 4-5 Minuten und sowas 3D gedruckt, bis du
halt 2 Stunden am Drucken. Ich modell mir das nicht mit Laser. Ne, für die
Laser brauchst du ordentliche Sicherheitsgehäuse oder und auf jeden Fall musste ich immer
dran halt eine Brille anzuziehen. Also Laser ist echt nicht ohne. Natürlich kannst du
die YOLO Taktik fahren und denken ey passiert doch eh nix. Aber so ein Laser ins Auge ist
wirklich nicht ohne. Dann rauch dein Auge mal für kurze Zeit.
Ah das ist jetzt langweilig oder? Jetzt macht er irgendwelches, was für eine Programmiersprache
verwendet er bestimmt. Ja ok langweilig. Ok hier sieht man das fertige. Gut. Wisst ihr
warum das Display da vorne dran ist? Der einzige Grund warum das Ding ein Display hat ist weil
es geht. Ansonsten braucht die Displayanzeige da vorne wirklich niemand drauf. Es geht und
es sieht cool aus, das reicht ja schon als Rechtfertigung. Sonderlichen Mehrwert bietet
es jetzt nicht.
Der nächste Video, ich hab 3000 Euro verbrannt. Ah kann immer passieren.
So es sieht so aus als wäre das alles richtig funktioniert. Ich konnte nur unter 1,5 Stunden
Laufzeit haben. 1,5 Stunden Laufzeit ist schon nicht schlecht. Was ich mich jetzt frage ist,
ja gut ich mein kommt natürlich auf die Auslastung vom Raspberry Pi an und alles. Das Ding kriegst
du wahrscheinlich in einer Viertelstunde Leerwende wenn du willst. Wobei eine Viertelstunde auch
vollkommen ausreicht. Was ich mich frage ist geht das automatisch wieder an. Wenn die Batterie
leer sind, also der Sinn von der USB ist ja zum Beispiel wenn die Batterien leer gehen
dass es den Raspberry Pi runterfährt. So das funktioniert in dem Fall. Die Frage ist wenn
dann, also mal angenommen die Batterien sind leer, der Strom ist wieder hergestellt geht
der Raspberry Pi dann wieder an. Das hängt von dieser USB ob die das checkt. Also ob das
funktioniert, da gibt es Probleme. Aber ob die wieder angeht, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Also, du hast dich schon mal ziemlich schnell die Batterien hier falsch rum eingelegt und
dann macht es kaputt. Das ist alles China Zeug. Ist halt billig, hat aber so die ein oder
andere usability Probleme. Aber die Glas Seite die ich gerade mit dem Laser gegattert habe,
das ist schon cool, das ist schon nice. Okay, easy. Ja Leute, ehrlich gesagt, wie gesagt
ich habe null vorbereitet für den Stream. Ich habe nichts was ich euch heute noch zeigen
kann, was ich reden kann oder sonst wie. Zumal ich auch ziemlich müde bin. Ich sage das war
heute ein kurzer Stream, eineinhalb Stunden. Ich werde jetzt schon aufgehen. Mach Spendenziel
Quatsch. Quatsch. Ich kann mir das ohne Probleme leisten, auch spenden, aber ich sehe es nicht
ein. Für was was ich so gut wie nie verwende. Aber irgendeine nicht hosten kann, der es
nötig hat. Okay Leute, wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten Stream, dann wird wahrscheinlich
weiter programmiert, denke ich mal. Morgen Livestream nach 5G Injektion kommt drauf an.
Was das ZDF streamt auf Twitch? Das ist doch Chebat, oder? Macht es nicht. Das wäre es
jetzt. Mich würde ich jetzt nicht gewundert, die versuchen ja immer mal wieder hip zu sein.
Du schaust jetzt die M. Könnte ich machen? Nein, habe ich wirklich nicht dran gedacht.
Die Dänen kriegen jetzt wahrscheinlich auf den Sack. Alles klar, wir sehen uns, bis
dann, tschüss.